we now have reaction coming through from
Ukraine's President Vladimir zielinski
who spoke in following uh the ceremony
in Moscow in which Moscow claimed
occupied regions of Ukraine into Russia
let's listen in today we're here
in the community of free Nations we can
see who is threatening us who is
prepared to kill us and mamas who would
not stop
at any atrocity in order to expand the
area of control on the 24th of February
the first full-scale strike was carried
out against Ukraine that was the first
one Russia was not stopping and would
not have stopped on our borders had we
not stopped it other countries would be
would be jeopardized the Baltic states
Moldova Georgia Kazakhstan Russia
wanted to subordinate various nations of
Europe and Asia just six months ago
this crime is stopped in Ukraine it was
stopped near Kiev and Japanese and as of
style in Sumi region in kharkiv region
in Snake Island on Snake Island it will
be stopped in donbath and in the south
of Ukraine when we liberate them and
especially in Crimea in a free Ukrainian
Crimea all of our country's territory
will be liberated from this enemy it is
not just the enemy of Ukraine it is the
enemy of life itself of humanity of Law
and Truth Russia knows this Russia feels
our power it can see that here in
Ukraine we are proving the strength of
our values and this is why it is in a
hurry it is staging this path and
annexation it is trying to steal that
which does not belong to it it wants to
kill to torture to Blackmail and lie in
order to rewrite history and redraw
borders Ukraine will not allow this
today I held a meeting with the staff of
the general staff and the chief
commander-in-chief the security Council
of Ukraine we have decided first only by
strengthening Ukraine and chasing the
occupiers from our territory shall we
shall we return
to our borders we will cover this road
only through negotiations will we will
return to negotiations Ukraine has
always proposed negotiations on Fair
terms but clearly
this Russian president
we can't deal with him he does not know
what is humanity and honor therefore we
are prepared for a dialogue with Russia
but with a different President of Russia
and third
we must confirm legally everything we
have achieved in reality in Ukraine it
is in Ukraine that the fate of democracy
is decided in confrontation with tyranny
it is here within the state borders of
Ukraine that we can confirm the strength
of the borders of All European countries
we can guarantee that nobody will dare
to
um returned tyranny to our continent it
is here that the values of our
euro-atlantic community has been have
been revived
um by a people that is fighting for
freedom
and with other nations that help us in
the struggle we are real allies
with NATO uh we have covered this road
to Nato and in actual fact we have
proven that we are compatible with the
standards of the alliance they are real
um on the battlefield in every aspect of
our cooperation we trust one another we
help one another and we are protecting
defending one another and that is our
alliance this is an actual Alliance
today Ukraine
is making is
so president zielinski announcing that
Ukraine is uh formally applying to Fast
Track its membership of the NATO
military
Alliance uh that's it for the news this
hour but there'll be more updates at the
top of the hour with Nick Clark after
the stream thanks for watching